talk a little bit about the power of
training i mean you're you're you chose
to be a coach i know you've had coaching
you've had mentors
um talk a little bit about the power of
that yeah i mean i really feel that you
know in in business
you need you need accountability you
need somebody to reach out to i mean if
you think about any any business
it always had the board of directors
somebody above the ceo
that and then ultimately the
shareholders above that
so you're always being accountable so
you know being in business can be a
lonely place at the top so
um to have training to have mentorship
is really really important it's
something i've learned over the years
i didn't when i was young i didn't think
i needed help
i just went out there and thought i'm
just going to do this myself work really
hard
i'm savvy i know everything um i don't
need anybody's help
and i sort of push people away doug as
you've mentioned before who i work with
who's my cousin
he reached out to me many years ago and
said tony you know do you want some help
doing this
and i avoided taking his calls to be
honest and
i just didn't need anybody and that was
what was that was that like an eager
thing or
it sounds arrogant but it's more to do
with i just
didn't think i needed any help it wasn't
because i thought i
knew everything but it's just thought
well why would somebody else
who doesn't know exactly what i'm doing
be able to help me
right um but i was wrong on that
why were you wrong and do you regret do
you regret not taking help sooner
absolutely yeah talk to me about that
once again i said being a ceo of
business is a very lonely place and you
know you
you're making decisions all the time the
art of business is making decisions
making quick decisions making decisions
which you know
based on you know what you're trying to
get out of it
and if you've got nobody to sound bored
off of
uh nobody to sort of share ideas with
then
how do you know it's the right decision
yeah you know where
just having a mentor or having somebody
to bounce those ideas off of
even if they don't know exactly what
your business is by you
by you um verbalizing it by you talking
to somebody
helps you sort of enforce that decision
in your head
whether it's the right thing to make
sense the problem is as well tony is if
you haven't got an official mentor
or a business coach or a trainer to to
follow and to guide you
i feel you'll end up getting advice from
people anyway
maybe your wife or your kids
or dave down the pub and and they're
going to give you terrible advice
yeah so you may as well just get advice
from the right
people absolutely absolutely because
everyone talks talks about their issues
and
it's like who are the five people that
you're speaking with who are the five
people you're getting advice from your
bounce night is off
okay are those five people financially
free
if not if not maybe you need to find
some different people
what have you been your biggest lessons
mistakes
because i know you've had some real
problems your business
oh my goodness you lost a lot of money a
few years back
yep i mean what did you learn from that
once again
it was it was you know by not
you